Vivek ramaswamy is an extraordinarily
successful entrepreneur the founder of a
major biopharmaceutical company the
co-founder of strive Asset Management
he's the author of a couple of books
notably woke Inc he's a graduate of
Harvard and Yale and now Vivek is
seeking the Republican nomination for
president in 2024.
every presidential campaign has The
Usual Suspects the governors and the
Senators and sometimes the congressmen
and then every so often
some totally unexpected figure pops up
and shakes up the race
and this year that person would be my
friend
the fake ramaswamy Vivek thank you for
making the time I know you're very busy
on the campaign Trail it's good to be
honest my first stop after getting off
the CPAC stage here so that was fun and
uh and you know what we're having fun
with this when you first told me that
you were thinking about maybe running
for president you know my only thought
was huh
I would have I would have expected he'd
wait until 2028 but that was I was not
surprised that you would I don't even
know if you knew that you might run
someday but but I did I sort of had this
thought of good instincts yes yeah and
but you've you've jumped right into the
race A lot of people do not know who you
are exactly the people who do know who
you are have been saying
don't write this guy out just because
you haven't heard his name this is a
very impressive guy who brings in a
wealth of Knowledge from a lot of
different segments of the public life
and I happen to agree with that take so
I'm very excited to help introduce you
to the rest of the public thank you man
now now that I've been very nice to you
I'm going to be cold I'm going to grill
you I'm going to give you very tough
questions oh like like you've done in
the past I I know the real Michaels I'm
ready for you okay first question
who's your favorite President Thomas
Jefferson
I think Thomas Jefferson embodies the
founding culture in the United States so
I'm a big founding principles guy for
sure actually the whole premise of my
candidacy by the way is Reviving the
principles that set the nation into
motion this actually should be a really
easy election there's hard elections
where everyone agrees on the basic
principles and you disagree on some
really important policy issue this
should be an easy election where
Free Speech open debate all the stuff
that Thomas Jefferson wrote about in the
Declaration of Independence and Beyond
this is the stuff that actually most
Americans agree on and yet we live in
this moment where they're artificially
fraught but anyway why is Thomas
Jefferson my favorite President it's not
just because he wrote the Declaration of
Independence and as a whatever startup
guy as a Founder as a company you guys
built companies I'm a big on mission
statement that is the best mission
statement for a nation ever written the
Declaration of Independence but there
was also a founding culture to go along
with it right he was a polymath he was
as were many of these guys Benjamin
Franklin on down these guys even even
John Adams now people know this about
him but he studied Sanskrit later in
life these guys yeah he actually after
he left the White House and he would and
these guys they were also kind of
boastful about it he would put it in his
letters to TJ because he knew that
posterity would read about he says oh if
I was to do it again I would have been a
Sanskrit scholar rather than you know
being the US president yeah exactly but
but so there was a little Showmanship
there but there was Showmanship grounded
in reality and I kind of love the
Showmanship too because it just it's
real in a certain sense they're proud of
it yeah and so Thomas Jefferson he's
writing the Declaration of independence
with his hand but he realizes that oh
well you know what I don't really like
the chair I'm sitting in so I guess I
would love this idea of a swivel chair
didn't exist before then so he just made
one he invented it he invented the
swivel chair to write the Declaration of
Independence so that he could actually
write the great founding document
providing the greatest mission statement
for not only the United States or a
nation but the Free World As We Know It
that's missing today I think we miss the
people who look at somebody else's
domain and say hey that's for somebody
else who has expertise over there and
I'm not supposed to do that because I'm
not trained versus saying you know what
I'm a human being we have free will no
one is born with all the knowledge they
need to have to do anything and if I'm
hungry enough most things I could
probably figure it out and if I feel
like doing I'm going to do it whether
somebody tells me to or not that's part
of what we're missing too is not just
the founding principles but a little bit
of that founding culture and the other
reason I like Thomas Jefferson from the
standpoint of History
is that as is now all too trite and
familiar I mean he he was a flawed man
he did not live up to his own ideals he
was in a very real sense of the term
hypocrite life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness but not for his slaves now
of course
this desserts we talked about over the
last few years it's been over talked
about because that's all anybody can
fixate on about one about an important
man's Legacy who had much more to him
than the worst aspects of his of his
hypocrisies but he's also a reminder
that hypocrisy is only made possible by
the existence of ideals okay there's a
reason we can't call a big part of my
speech just now was about the CCP
say what you will about the Chinese
Communist party you can never call them
Hypocrites because in order to be a
hypocrite you had to have ideals in the
first place you can call Thomas
Jefferson a hypocrite because he had
ideals and so he's a reminder of not
only the existence of ideals but the
fact that we as human beings are flawed
deeply flawed there will be people 250
years from now that look back at us
today and say weren't they Hypocrites we
just don't know what basis they're going
to have for saying it but it's
definitely going to happen the La Roche
Focus said that hypocrisy is the tribute
Vice pays to Virtue that's exactly right
Festival in the white house maybe we got
to talk they've been trying to can me
from daily wire for years so that would
be a great opportunity just keep say the
same play for another about two years
and then in January 2025 we'll talk
right so
speaking of these great men and these
great writers and thinkers
which book has most influenced your
political views
question most that's a pretty high bar I
would say Friedrich Von Hayek's
constitution of Liberty
I think it's an underappreciated work
because
you know people read the summaries of
someone like Hayek and then they
conflate it with like a nozick or they
conflate it with just the broader theory
of libertarian thought Austrian
Economist Von mises and I love all these
guys but they actually had very
different and distinctive views from one
another I think Hayek Was A Cut Above
heck was A Cut Above because
his case for you know what is in
bastardized form referred to as
libertarianism it's so reductionist I I
kind of cringe as I even acknowledge
that description but
it was really grounded in fundamental
human respect
human dignity and so so his view was
that
you know I'm gonna
distill it to sort of a modern practical
form here but let's just take the
arguments about redistribution or
whatever his point would be look if the
argument for redistribution is grounded
in
human Worth to say that your human worth
is tied to the number of green pieces of
paper that sit in your bank account
that's the basis for making sure
everyone has the same equal number of
green pieces of paper
you've got it backwards because you're
actually committing a moral error you're
tying someone's moral worth
to their financial worth right and
that's actually what creates the
conditions for rampant Mutual disrespect
amongst what should be co-equal citizens
and so people miss the fact that his
case against unbridled Merit and
excellence and and what we would call
free market capitalism today
was grounded not in some economic
account which you know is maybe better
tied to Milton Friedman's tradition but
is actually tied to the basic Dignity of
man itself and the basic Dignity of
citizens of Nations who were co-equal
citizens regardless of the number of of
green pieces of paper in some ways were
the problem is actually the
redistributionists are the ones who also
commit the error of fetishizing the
accumulation of paper right when in fact
there's more to life there's more to
human worth there's more to human value
than that and so I thought that was that
was I think what makes some of his work
profound and I think should be more
persuasive to more people than you would
think speaking of relating to all of our
citizens some of whom we don't always
want to relate to
what is one issue on which you could see
yourself Reaching Across the aisle and
what is one issue on which you could
probably never see yourself Reaching
Across the aisle so I got to say one
thing off the off the gate here of that
event
I don't really care about partisan
politics that much like partisan
politics boards me so like even this
talk of the aisle makes me you know
recoil a little bit because it's so
reductionist I just don't even think
Republican versus Democrat is the most
relevant political distinction in
America today I mean I'm an Unapologetic
conservative and we can talk about My
Views but the Republican party and what
does that mean right I mean the
Democratic party what does that mean
these are these are relatively
incoherent Concepts
it's sort of designed to shoehorn the
real political debates into these sort
of artificial categories I think the the
real political divide in the modern West
certainly in America but in the modern
West more broadly is
this divide between what I call the
great reset and the great Uprising right
the great Uprising is the response to
the great reset a view that says you
have to dissolve the boundaries between
the private sector and the public sector
between nations between the online world
and the offline world so everybody can
work men and women yeah that's a
different dissolution of boundaries
actually between the genders it's all
about dissolving boundaries
so that the leaders of Institutions may
work together towards the common
Collective good that's the vision of the
great reset
and it's different from the side I'm on
the if I had to pick between the two the
great Uprising which says hell no to
that Vision we the citizens of nations
in America the citizen of this nation as
a citizen of this nation say we decide
in a self-governing Democratic Republic
how we sort out our political
differences that's really the divide the
managerial class versus the everyday
citizen
you know one way I might frame it as
well is between those who are
unapologetically pro-american and those
who are and I think these exist in
America today those were fundamentally
anti-American okay there's a distinction
there
the good news is that's an 80 20 divide
it's not a 50 50 divide so here's what
I'll say that's the way I draw the aisle
I'm not Reaching Across the aisle I'm
unapologetically in the pro-american
camp and I'm not making a concession to
the anti-American Camp other than
through persuasion to get them to join
our camp
there's nothing about me that will cause
me to reach across the aisle to the
great reset I am on the side of
believing that I'm not a citizen of the
globe or a citizen of the world I'm a
citizen of a nation and I'm proud of it
so draw it that way there's no Reaching
Across the aisles but Democrat versus
Republican I mean these things don't
even these words these are words they're
meaningless of course there are many
issues in which I'll bring a lot of
Democrats along with me I mean I think
one of my proposals is to make political
expression a civil right in America
right to say that if you can't fire
somebody or de-platform somebody because
they're black or gay or Muslim or white
or Hindu or Jewish or whatever that you
shouldn't be able to fire them just
because they're outspoken conservative
right I guess theoretically means
outspoken liberal that's not relevant
the conservative piece is what's
relevant because that's what's happening
nobody gets fired for me because it
doesn't you know so it would be silly
for me to say but in principle you know
I would say the same thing but why do I
bring up that example
today a lot of the people who stand up
to me are sort of federal Democrats that
don't know the first thing about
American history legal history when they
say oh no that would be a bad idea when
they don't know it's it's kind of rather
embarrassing to them when they find out
that actually this protection exists in
a good number of states
including an especially blue states that
actually passed this protection during
like the bush era in California for
example because they were fearful of the
the expansive you know military State
under Bush and Dick Cheney that they
were going to suppress people who wanted
to stand up to the Post 9 11 you know
expansive State well they said no no we
need to give space to those people to
have those protections from getting
fired and so it sort of proves that that
isn't a Republican or Democratic issue
but it's just you know an example of the
kind of thing that I'm in favor of one
of my you know I wouldn't call it a
signature policy I just view it as a
simple it's on the list right it sure
would have a lot of support yeah that
that one but I was about to say a
different one which is
you know look I think that if you can't
smoke an addictive cigarette by the age
of 18 if you can't have an addictive sip
of alcohol by the age of 21 I don't
think you should be using an addictive
social media product like Tick Tock
before the age of 15 either that's not a
partisan point it's not a republican
voice on a democratic point I think it
makes sense you know even principled
Libertarians God love them but kids
aren't the same as adults I think
everyone acknowledges that so there's a
lot to to sort of my policy perspectives
that you know transcend the traditional
partisan boundaries or whatever you know
call that Reaching Across the aisle call
it Reaching Across the aisle but I don't
even pay much heed to the traditional
party which aisle yeah I'm like not I'm
not a politician it like this stuff is
is silly to me I'm an Unapologetic
America First conservative will not
apologize for it but I think that just
reciting those slogans means very little
and until you first ReDiscover what
America is I I love the idea of banner
if we got at least one supporter for
this proposal of banning social media
for kids I think you know I love cigars
I'm not a cigarette fan but I love
cigars and some people say it's a vice
well at least advice sharpens your mind
a little social media especially if
you're a kid it melts your brain oh it
comes out your ear it's designed to melt
your brain because it's picking at
insecurities I mean Mark Zuckerberg's
core Insight he was a year ahead of me
when I was in college and you know
Facebook was invented before to call it
that while I was in college
it's designed to prey on your
insecurities right I mean you're going
to click on this versus this faster
gives you a window into your soul deeper
than you have into your own soul yep and
so that's what it's about so so we can
have that debate about what that means
for the loss of virtue amongst adults
that lends us vulnerable to this kind of
algorithmic
call it exploitation or manipulation but
adults are adults it's their job to to
fortify themselves in the offline world
that's a whole separate and deep
discussion but for kids Yeah by
definition you haven't formed that moral
or psychic Foundation
and there's a reason why China doesn't
allow the version of sexualized Dance
videos or whatever that exist on Tick
Tock here over there it's about math and
Engineering in the Chinese version bite
dance operated version of their product
over there it's like you know they send
fentanyl across our Southern Border in
Mexico effectively through cheap raw
materials that they sell to the cartels
this is digital fentanyl if I had to
take the analogy further it's Financial
fentanyl in the form of national debt
but that's a whole separate discussion
of our broader addiction to China but
bringing me back even China actually
I'll go there too I don't think that has
to be a partisan point I think that
recognizing that the CCP is the single
greatest threat that America faces
over the next 30 Years
that ought to be a point of bipartisan
consensus it isn't I think that we need
conservatives who are able to in Greater
detail make the case for that to the
American people make the case because
there's going to be some sacrifices in
weaning off of China Goods yeah we got
addicted to cheap stuff it's a form of
addiction we gotta I mean we get
addicted to everything from the fentanyl
to the digital fentanyl to the cheap
stuff
but
but we can make these sacrifices if we
know what we're sacrificing for yeah
it's this thing we call America let's
make sure our children and grandchildren
aren't a bunch of Chinese serfs that are
somehow citizens of some sort of
co-equal bilateral Global governing
equilibrium created between the United
States and China which is what China
hopes for no they should be the citizens
of the greatest nation on Earth but that
requires some short run sacrifice
I think America could use bluntly a
little less Chamberlain and a little
more Churchill and and you know I think
that's a big part of the premise for my
candidacy is to deliver that kind of
vision speaking of China yep president
ramaswamy gets the call China has
invaded Taiwan what do you do
so invaded is what we're talking about
here not blockade right
either yeah so because because I think
the scenarios are basically different
I do think that we have to vigorously
protect Taiwan I don't like enmeshing
ourselves in Foreign Wars that don't
matter
I'm on that side of the Ukraine issue I
think we have overspent and it's a
lesson we ought to learn for a long time
to come I take that a fraction of that
money and protector on Southern border
but the reason Taiwan matters
is that unfortunately a modern way of
life depends on it I mean the
semiconductor chips that power our
phones the semiconductor chips that
power our refrigerators they kept this
water cold before we're drinking it all
of that comes from this tiny little
island nation off the Southeast coast of
China and it is a shame that we ever got
here
but we are where we are and so if China
holds the keys to Taiwan that's the
final step in the long run bargain
they've always wanted to reach with the
United States the final coup they wanted
to achieve in the 50-year game that they
played with Henry Kissinger and won
without our knowing it which is to say
that there's a grand bargain
we get your intellectual property
and we'll make your stuff
that's what China is saying to the U.S
so if the U.S right now I mean we have
no reason to accept that bargain it
would be it would be foolish right
because we can Source the stuff from
somewhere else right so we have that
leverage going for us
however once China's squatting on Taiwan
they can really squeeze in The Leverage
out of that negotiation and then it's a
permanent bipolar new status quo now
here's where I'm at I don't think
they're quite yet ready to invade Taiwan
I don't think they will be ready to
invade by the time I take office should
I succeed in January 2025 and I think
there's things we can do that can pull
the economic rug out from under China to
effectively defeat them I say defeat
them in the sense that the fall of the
CCP may not be as far away as people
think
Xi Jinping actually did a lot of damage
to China over the last year as part of
his quest to hold on to power I think
there's actually a an interesting window
here that we might be working within
that just like we found out Putin's
military capacity was sort of an emperor
has no clothes situation
not so much for Chinese military
capacity but even for Chinese economic
capacity and remember the grand bargain
between the CCP and the people is at
least you take care of our material way
of life and we'll seed our freedoms to
you but that doesn't work if they're no
longer supporting the material way of
life and so I would go so far as to
ban most U.S businesses from doing
business in China unless and until the
CCP either Falls or reforms its
behaviors now that'll hurt us a little
bit it'll hurt them more I think our
willingness to make that sacrifice it's
not a small sacrifice
probably is the single greatest lever to
make sure that we never have to make it
you got to think about this stuff it's
not static and so for me
I think then also semiconductor capacity
here at home is is rising too so then
that Gap is going to close we do have
this little divest to invest thing going
on in the US Navy you're familiar with
this or not no so it's it's a long story
but we have a divest to invest program
where we're decommissioning ships in the
South Pacific and so our Nader of
military capacity in the South Pacific
China's already got more you know more
ships in its Navy than we do but our
Nader really is kind of going to be in
the 2026 2027 time frame Xi Jinping is
not quite ready it's I think that's what
he's playing for so I think the window
between January 2025 when if I'm
successful and I take office
and in mid-2026 or 20 to 27 that's the
window where we got to pull the economic
rug out from under China declare
independence from China decouple but
actually I think the way it's going to
play out is that guts the economic
fortitude of the CCP they lose their
mandate in China itself and we actually
are in a very different situation that
we should have been and start to get
back on the right track that we would
have been on had had the decisions not
been made in 1970s to totally couple
with China will you I know that's long
and complicated but hopefully some of
that made sense it's a good answer and
you've partially answered my next
question which is on trade the
Republican Party founded on
protectionism and tariffs then for much
of the 20th century certainly the second
part of the 20th century the Republican
party is the party of free trade now the
Republican party doesn't quite know what
it is CBD right TBD so trade trade I'm
not a protectionist okay but vis-a-vis
China the reason I adopt policies that
align with those Advanced by
protectionists is for national security
reasons right because because I think
that this is about
China is operating according to
mercantilist rules deputizing capitalism
I use capitalism and air quotes to
advance their geopolitical end of
achieving long-run even military parity
with the United States in China economic
policy and military policy are two sides
of the same coin we in the west in the
United States in particular adopt a
duelist view that military policies over
here and economic policies over here but
that was what China exploited that was
the whole wedge they exploited because
they view them as part and parcel of the
same and you know what got to give it to
somebody when they win they won that
game Henry Kissinger was wrong China was
right
but I think that that's with respect to
China and I and I don't think that we
should conflate that with coddling
American workers who don't need coddling
I think we also look at a
look at a couple other dimensions here
one is the the stand the dollar as the
U.S Reserve as the reserve currency of
the world the US dollar being the
original records I think it's a good
thing
however that does create some
distributive consequences here at home
right so was it dollars Reserve currency
means means there's an extra bid for the
dollar
above and beyond what would have existed
under free market conditions where the
dollar was not the reserve currency why
do we want the dollar as a reserve
currency we then control the financial
system we can freeze the terrorists
assets on demand whatever
it's a good thing for America but what
does that mean it means on average that
tilts the scales of U.S exports costing
more to other countries and U.S Imports
costing less so that systematically does
disfavor U.S manufacturers so I think
there's some areas where we have to not
be willfully blind to distributive
consequences we create at home from
policies that are still good for the
nation as a whole and they're mindful to
implement other policies
exactly to make sure that anything
that's protecting the nation as a whole
that we don't abandon the dollar is the
reserve currency of the world but say
that we're in that together and that
we're not just
um blind purposefully blind to the
consequences of who's left holding the
bag as a consequence so I think we've
got to be in that together but I but I
think that that is is at the margin
right and so I think that some of this
case for industrial policy bleeds into
and they even take support from people
like me because I'm coming at it from a
very different angle vis-a-vis China
to Marshall support for what could
easily devolve into a form of really
economic laziness I do think that U.S
competitiveness is in part created by
having our feet held to the fire and
being the best on the planet
means that we're actually doing it
because we're the best on the planet
and so vis-a-vis China what is
decoupling from China means it's not
going to all be restoring into the
United States although it will involve
some of that but it'll also involve
looking at you know southeast Asia India
South America and I think that's got to
be a all of the above approach because
the real objective is economic
independence from an enemy and I use the
word enemy intentionally here vis-a-vis
communist China
but I think that that's something that
uh that we can that we can do in a more
focused way with respect to China so
we're talking about the free flow of
goods and services how about the flow of
people on immigration assuming that you
are opposed to Illegal immigration and
would like to stop that then there are
some other questions the question is
what to do with the people already here
does one provide a path to citizenship
say for the illegal aliens who are
currently in the country and then
further polls have suggested that many
many Americans want to reduce not just
illegal immigration but legal
immigration as well so when it comes to
Legal immigration would president Rama
Swami restrict it expand it or keep it
about the same so on illegal immigration
I'm a hardliner I believe in the use of
the U.S military to protect our border
it's a shame that that's a controversial
idea that using our military to protect
our border is actually the most
controversial use of our military when
in fact using it to protect somebody
else's borders somehow perfectly fine so
I'm you know what you would call a
hardliner on the issue of illegal
immigration on legal immigration I think
that we've gotten it wrong we do we have
a policy of accidental immigration when
I think we should have a policy of
intentional immigration
we have Lottery systems for H1B visas I
mean this makes no sense why on Earth
would you want to leave it to a lottery
when you could actually just pick the
best ones to actually come best ones as
measured by commitment to the country
likelihood of making contribution to the
country based on their track record and
even their educational economic position
in a different country so I believe in
meritocratic points-based Immigration
now I I've heard that answer before okay
someone is a skilled at some job and so
the company says we really need this
person in that case but you said
something very interesting you said
commitment to the country which would
not presumably just be
quantifiable Civic commitment yeah so I
think there's there's this step later on
of first of all I think we need to
bolster the citizenship tests in this
country not just knowledge but even even
enthusiasm commitment I think at best a
lot of people grow up and are born as
Citizens just because they inherit their
citizenship and they don't know the
first thing about what it means to be an
American well a lot of immigrants come
to the country today and they're every
bit as bad what they don't really know
either no I think it's got to be
somebody who played allegiance to that
flag and understands the history behind
it understands how we got to where we
are understands what makes America great
and then wants to be a part of it
and so I'm big on this idea of Revival
of citizenship and I I what I'm about to
say is a jokingly okay uh it's not it's
not a policy that I think we can
actually Implement uh so these are risky
things to say as a political candidate
but I don't care because it's just the
kind of thing we ought to talk about
openly
I don't hate the idea of pick a sum of
money fifty thousand dollars hundred
thousand dollars whatever it takes for
somebody to go make a pretty good life
for themselves in some developing nation
and God knows where take the decisions
of this country and say what if you
don't want to be part of this country
and you never want to come back the only
condition is you never come back
here's the money go make a great life
for yourself because if you don't
believe in what this nation stands for
you don't have to be a part of it that's
okay
you know what the only thing then we got
to really secure the Border because
what's going to happen is a lot of going
to kind of come back and they're going
to make sure we keep our end of the
bargain but there's a thought experiment
for the kind of nation that I think we
need is a nation of citizens who are
actually committed
to what that flag symbolizes right and I
think that immigrants if we're selecting
them in the right way through
meritocratic admission not just through
contributions but through commitment to
the nation I think that can be part of
the national Civic revitalization as
well I like that the be my guest plan
yeah you don't like the country be my
guest yeah yeah exactly certainly leave
well this ties in with another question
many on the left
don't like the country they mock the
idea of patriotism they say that this
country was evil and rotten from the
very beginning we've heard that for
years
increasingly a number of people on the
right
seem to have trouble with patriotism and
love of country because they view
America as a woke Empire that is
dedicated perhaps first and foremost to
spreading I don't know transgenderism
overseas and that America basically has
lost its way and so it's very difficult
to
to be patriotic how would president Rama
Swami
recultivate this patriotic love of
country in Americans on the left and the
right so I think first is it does start
at the Top This is a cultural tone that
we're able to set for the country I
think Ronald Reagan did it he drove a
national Revival the last time America
was International identity crisis which
was in the late 70s
I'm committed to
restoring the ideals that set this
nation into motion 250 years ago okay I
don't think we achieved National Unity
by showing up in the proverbial middle
say hold hands compromise guys can't you
get along Kumbaya that ain't happening
okay if that was ever gonna happen
that's not happening today
I think we achieve National Unity by
embracing unapologetically embracing the
extremism
the radicalism of the ideas that set
this nation into motion Free Speech open
debate unbridled meritocracy
self-governance over aristocracy these
are the things that it really means to
be American a belief in the Declaration
of Independence even if we channel into
that declaration of independence from
China get that policy in there too but
truth be told that this is this is what
it means to be American and I think I
think done this way
we actually find the common thread that
unites us across our diversity
and I think our diversity is not our
strength our diversity isn't even
beautiful who cares we have a bunch of
different shades of melon in here right
I'm looking at the camera crew a bunch
of us here Sicilian it's always been
kind of a limited you know exactly
racially ambiguous we've got a spectrum
of melanin content I think it is utterly
meaningless it is neither beautiful nor
our strength unless there's something
greater that binds us together across
our diversity
without that we're really just going
through the motions there's a bunch of
higher mammals like a bunch of animals
roaming across this American plain yeah
sure America is beautiful but sort of a
lot of other countries visually speaking
what makes America actually a beautiful
makes America itself is the existence of
that common thread of ideals
and that that's what makes e pluribus
unum from anyone mean something and I
think that
I think that a policy agenda that flows
from those principles I mean what have I
pledged to that no other
U.S presidential candidate has ever done
I think but certainly this cycle no
one's yet done is ending affirmative
action simple thing you can do it with
an executive order stroke of a pen
executive order one one two four six
okay
Lyndon Johnson created affirmative
action in America any president
including a Republican president
including Donald Trump could have ended
it
I know why they didn't I talked to many
of the policy people I pushed them on
this they said that well it's not a
political hill we wanted to die on
maybe it's hard if you're a white guy in
the White House stand affirmative action
I don't know maybe it's because I'm 37
maybe because I'm not well I I don't
maybe it's because I don't care I'm in
affirmative action abandon climate
religion with the heart of climate
religion is really apologizing for the
success of the modern West and modern
America as we know it I refuse to
apologize for that
but I think that these can actually be
unifying ideas in some ways these are
extreme ideas to some people but I think
it's by embracing the extremism of the
ideals that underlie them that'll
actually unify Americans across the
lines and not just identity politics but
even partisan politics and again
you know maybe I'll eat my words but I
think 2024 will be a landslide election
and I'm bluntly running because I think
I'm going to be the guy that delivers it
I'm not kidding you're I think it's
going to happen I've told people from
the beginning as I mentioned I said
don't underestimate this guy uh he's
thought through these things and there
there is a coherence maybe people
totally reject your agenda but there is
a coherence to it and so let's bring
that coherence from the national malaise
that you're describing right down to the
fundamental political unit right now
marriage rates are at or near all-time
lows uh birth rates at all-time lows
you're seeing abortion is still pretty
high so the American family is in free
fall
What policies would president Rama Swami
undertake to reverse that decline of the
family so I think there is a bit of an
assault on the Family
undertaken through the assault on
religious liberty in our country too so
this is a longer discussion about
religious liberty but I think it's
closely linked to family I I think the
equality act which which uh I don't
think was appropriately termed but
nonetheless could be a Pandora's Box if
we let it be I think for me as president
it's important to hold the line there to
say that now you're not going to create
the conditions for using that law as a
basis for labeling a religious
organization to be a hate group or
whatever that changes their lending
standards does it not already the
quality it already does right it already
worsened it but I think it was it was a
symptom of a deeper Trend in this
country so one of the things that I'm
able to do because I'm not a Christian
nationalist I'm not even I'm not even
Christian Hindu right I went to
Christian Schools or whatever and I'm a
deeply faith-based person
I can do what somebody who
wears their Christianity on their sleeve
can't do and I don't mean that in a bad
way I just mean that literally in modern
American culture it's really difficult
for them to do what I can do in offering
a staunch defense of not another inch
budging on the issue of religious
liberty and I think that's in
intricately linked to family formation
as well now
I'm very clear about what my priorities
are and what they what they aren't and
there's some things that I think are
important that still aren't my
priorities one of the things it's my
belief that you do five or six things
and I've laid out what those five or six
things are you do those five or six
things well as you as president you're
gonna be one of the greatest presidents
in modern history so for me that's
shutting down the administrative State
actually I mean I've identified specific
government agencies to shut down have
specifically flagged the Department of
Education I've specifically flagged the
FBI in the department of education's
case it needs to be shut down and not
come back in the FBI's case we need to
shut it down and create something new to
take its place now how do you do it
there are so many presidential probably
every Republican presidential candidate
I don't know about the FBI but has said
I'm going to shut down the Department of
Education and then none of them ever get
it done yeah because they all have a
flawed view of article two of the
Constitution they think they need
Congress to do it I think it's a mistake
I don't think they need Congress to do
it I think the Constitution says that
the president of the United States runs
the executive branch of the government
if you run the executive branch of the
government that mean you run the
executive branch of the government
maybe it's my private sector view here
maybe it's not being a politician but I
can hear that Mike I I did go to law
school but here it's actually my private
sector view that allows me to interpret
the Constitution as it ought to be
interpreted here which is that
if someone works for you and you can't
fire them
that means they don't work for you it
means you work for them
because you're responsible for what they
do without having any authority over it
and that's the position and now I'm the
full running for the White House where
supposedly that's the position right
well well that's not going to change it
and I'm going to do it by executive
order I think that and it will be
litigated
but I think it's an interesting time to
do it there's a lot of things that give
me a sense of urgency to run for
president and this cycle to deliver this
change this is one of them I think we
have a supreme court that likely shares
my view of the Constitution here and
then we codify it in judicial precedent
to make sure that I'm not just the first
president but the first of many who will
actually be able to be the person who's
not only elected to run the government
but who actually does run the government
I give Donald Trump a lot of credit for
identifying that as a problem but if he
had actually fixed it we wouldn't be
sitting here talking about it the way
you're talking about executive power is
different than the way many Republicans
and conservatives in my lifetime have
talked about it many conservatives have
said we want fewer executive orders we
want less executive power you've
suggested perhaps executive power is a
way to protect the people in a one-way
ratchet as a downside as as a as a
downsizing mechanism so I think the
proper concern is that actually they
needed to make sure Congress authorized
funds before the president actually
spent it that's actually the historical
concern but the problem is there was the
inverse then built in by Congress which
is an overreach so this is like the 1974
impoundment protection act passenger
Nixon or or it was actually predict
against Steph Nixon was doing
which basically said that even if
Congress allocates money to a specific
agency and the president doesn't want to
spend that money the president still has
to I think it's unconstitutional I think
it's an unconstitutional overreach of
Congress
I think it's the symmetric point is the
president can't spend money the Congress
never budgeted but just because Congress
budgeted it doesn't mean the president
actually has to spend it if they see as
the leader of the executive branch that
there's waste fraud abuse and so on just
like a board of directors to a CEO says
here's your budget and research and
development that the CEO says that
actually I know that that project is
going to fail do I still have to spend
that money absolutely not it makes no
sense that ought to be the relationship
I think it is the relationship intended
between Congress and the president too
so I'm all about being very high
resolution on this stuff but I think as
it relates to
the exercise of restraint firing someone
not not hiring someone in an agency that
didn't exist but firing someone an
agency that does exist if you're running
the executive branch of the government
you've got to be able to do that or else
you're not actually running it so in a
one-way ratchet in the downsizing realm
yeah I think Executive Order is
absolutely an appropriate mechanism and
I think I'm unconstitutionally solid
grounds and I think the current Supreme
Court is highly likely to agree with me
which means we codify that in precedent
and I hope every future president
whether they're of the democratic party
or Republican party for that matter
thanks hopefully the next Administration
successful for actually delivering it I
in fact share this more expansive view
oh good okay okay all right good power
and as president you will be the top law
enforcement officer in the United States
the Capo de tuti copy
now we have a big crime problem in the
country right now
some say we have an over incarceration
problem
some look around at the murder rate they
say we have an under incarceration
problem some people say we need to
abolish prisons some people say we need
to build more prisons I guess one could
say that we should keep it exactly the
same where does President ramaswami
stand
I do think that there are too many
people incarcerated but there's a
problem of being over inclusive and
under inclusive right we're not actually
arresting people who ought to be
arrested and we're channeling that to
put a lot of people in prison and spend
a lot of money on it even in ways that
don't really respect even a Law and
Order culture because the asymmetry
between the two is itself I think a
legal betrayal this is this isn't a
policy answer but it's just a first
personal answer there's a guy who worked
for me who works for me I'm glad he I'm
glad it works for me but I'm not glad
about the circumstances that brought to
me he was a cop in Oregon
and he always wanted to be a cop that
was all he ever wanted to do in fact he
didn't even go to college because he
knew the fastest path to being a cop was
to actually join the military for a
couple of years because that would make
him eligible to be a cop it was his life
dream and then he goes to Oregon streets
of Portland Oregon and this is where he
can actually do some good as a cop until
they tell him here are the people you
can't arrest the people were actually
known to be burglars people who were
literally shooting meth on the street
you can see it but for whatever reason
they've decided that these are the
people you can't you can't arrest full
stop they've just made that executive
decision it doesn't make any sense why
and so he's left writing traffic tickets
for guys who speed or run red light so
he said I refuse to pull over the people
of speed I pulled the people who run red
lights but what I started to do is I
just refused to write him a ticket I
would just roll make them pull them over
and roll down the window and just say
sir do you mind not running the red
light next time and he'd say yeah sure
and let him go you can get away with
murder you should be able to get away
with the red light yeah and and I said
why did you even bother pulling him over
he said sometimes people would just
complain that I didn't pull him over if
they saw me so I'll just pull him over
and then and then have a conversation
because I couldn't I couldn't in good
conscience do that eventually he began
so jaded that he left law enforcement
altogether and works for me in a
different capacity but
I think I think the problem is the
uneven enforcement of laws as they stand
I'm going to talk about the doj uh you
know I'm a big fan of bringing the Civil
Rights Revolution into the 21st century
by applying it even-handedly we talked
about political expression as a civil
right that's a legislative point but I
do like uh one of the things I'm going
to do with the doj uh is actualize a
legal theory that I advanced in woke Inc
I think it's on Solid Ground if I may
say so myself but we lay out all the
historical legal precedence that would
justify it
so the Civil Rights protection against
discrimination on the basis of religion
doesn't just mean that you can't just
you cannot discriminate against employee
for their religion it also means that
you as the employer cannot force an
employee to bow down to your religion so
the question is whether the modern Dei
agenda or wokeness or whatever fits the
Supreme Court's test for what counts as
a religion turns out it meets that test
in Spades certain clothes you can't wear
words you can't say apologies you must
recite it's a systematic worldview
rather than a world view on a narrow set
of questions secular humanism meets the
Supreme Court's test work out
sacramental exactly so woke us you know
certainly meets that test to a T and so
actually much of what you see in
Corporate America even in the schools
Etc the enforcement of the Dei agenda is
actually a civil rights violation not
under a change law under existing law
today so I'll I'll instruct the
Department of Justice to prioritize
ridding ourselves of this National
Cancer by applying who would have ever
thought are civil rights laws evenly by
interpreting wokism as a religion by
acknowledging that wokism makes a
religion under the Supreme Court's test
under the legal definition of a religion
I've not won but two chapters of this
invoking was one chapter's wokeness is
like a religion actually the next
chapter is actually wokeness is
literally a religion so the first was
colloquial but the second one we
actually just legally meter it against
you know yeah law school Professor
approved you know I've had a bunch of
people kick the tires on this I think
this is a you know a co-developed it
actually with the with with a former law
professor of mine
I think this is actionable today you
know people ask what can a president do
about the woke epidemic well a lot of
it's just fundamentally illegal under
existing civil rights statutes and you
know what people may say oh that's
that's the free market
can't have it both ways okay if you want
to get rid of the civil rights laws and
the protected classes all together let's
have that conversation but so long as we
have it we've got to apply those
standards even-handedly and so when I
think about the core issues of national
identity and culture I do think that the
use of executive Authority even in legal
enforcement of civil rights violations
or legal violations that are rampant in
America today is a lever that I'll have
to use well speaking of enforcement
Vivek I would like to sit here all night
maybe have a couple drinks talk about
all of this but uh the policies
instituted by your campaign staff will
be enforced on me and I will be
defenestrated here one moment longer
let's roll great to see you as always
appreciate it thank you I'll see you on
the campaign Trail we'll see look
forward to it
foreign
[Music]